not a fan of the new segment we all know
Walsh will never admit he's wrong well
that's completely absurd you can't you
cannot say that once again this is a
false premise how can you say that I'll
never admit that I'm wrong because I've
never been wrong boom roasted so how do
you know that I wouldn't admit it think
about it I I've never had the
opportunity to admit that I'm wrong
about something because I've never been
wrong I would love to admit it I would
be the first one to admit that I was
wrong about something so I can put my
humility on display for all to see uh
but I've just I've unfortunately I've
been deprived of the opportunity to
admit I was wrong because I've just
literally never been wrong about a
single thing ever